eu já vi
e aí
e olha alguém que eles cá ou vai ou e
acreditar em
e eu sempre gosto de começar a
perguntando bom dia como é que vocês
estão só que japonês é provável que
ninguém sabe japonês aqui porque ninguém
me respondeu eu também não sei eu sempre
quis que eu não falo boa tarde eu falei
bom dia então tá beleza mas se fosse à
tarde tava lascado mas você não
respondeu porque você não falou japonês
agora eu queria fazer uma outra pergunta
cuja resposta você também não sabe com
antecedência e a pergunta é muito
simples é pergunta assim responda para
mim por favor mesmo que não souber
panparanpanpan por quê que o nosso sério
responde uma pergunta de música mas não
responde perguntei japonês o que que faz
o nosso cérebro funciona muito bem para
algumas coisas mas não também para
outras porque tem gente que ative o tem
gente que extrovertido tem gente vai bem
matemática tem gente que vai em
português porque tem joga amanhã
vídeogame de futebol mas mais importante
é que tem como a gente conseguir fazer
coisas legais que o nosso cérebro e
aprender a fazer coisas incríveis e
fazer o nosso potencial de atingir o
máximo eu falar para vocês que sim é
sobre a gente vai falar hoje a principal
porta para nós fazemos o nosso deve
funcionar de um jeito criativo é você
abrir os seus sentidos para ele
o japão um pouquinho hoje em cada uma
experiência sinestésica o tédio fala o
conhecimento só é válido quando
compartilhado tenho que ver como fazer
um teste diferente com vocês hoje não é
de onde vocês participassem que a gente
pudesse compartilhar um pouco dos
sentidos da vida né eu gosto sempre te
dar a palavra sentido é interessante que
ela tem um duplo sentido né qual o
sentido do caminho que eu tô indo qual o
sentido da vida e ao mesmo tempo e a
palavra que sempre que o sentidos tato
olfato visão e paladar audição para
começar eu queria uma frase do mais que
uma frase famosa do mais falar mente que
se abre a uma nova ideia ela jamais
volta ao tamanho original quando você
começa a fazer coisas novas eu sair eu
aprendi a fazer coisa nova o nosso
cérebro talvez seja uma das poucas
coisas no mundo que quanto mais mais
quase tudo na vida quanto mais menos
então por exemplo quanto mais dinheiro
você gasta menos dinheiro você tem
quanto mais pessoas têm elevador menos
pessoas ficar bem só que a mente é uma
coisa diferente quanto mais ideias você
tem mais fácil fica até a próxima e eu
gosto também de falar uma outra frase
que é muito legal que fala assim ó a
vida só tenho sentidos com
a grade é legal que eu falei essa frase
ó para gente começar a pensar sobre isso
a nossa ideia hoje eu falar sobre cinco
sentidos primeiro deles é sobre a visão
é legal palavra visionário já que está
falando sobre um pedex fala sobre o
futuro e dicionário tem a ver com a
visão como que você enxerga o futuro
como você consegue pensar um futuro
diferente é legal você precisa as
possibilidades eh enxergar você coisa
que ninguém chegou é você enxergar antes
dessas pessoas eu queria que tu não
pegasse por favor pega o seu papel aí
pega a sua a sua agenda aí que tá aí
junto com você eu queria que todo mundo
pegar seu papel e para começar a falar o
que eu queria falar hoje para vocês aqui
eu queria falar uma frase do
michelangelo em cada bloco de mármore
vejo uma estátua quem falou isso que é
um dos maiores artistas de todos os
tempos que não foi a tartaruga ninja foi
o artista mas eu queria que a gente
realmente percebesse que as coisas podem
serem incríveis quando você olha para
elas pessoal respondeu bem alto para mim
aí cada um pense uma coisa o quê que
essa folha pode ser fala para mim
e o que que essa folha pode ser ela pode
ser uma carta com ele que falou que
recebeu do pai essa carta pode ser o que
pode ser uma assinatura de um contrato
essa carta pode ser muita coisa essa
carta pode ser o mapa do tesouro essa
carta pode ser uma partitura de mozart
essa carta pode ser muita coisa que a
gente pode fazer se a gente tiver a
visão de enxergar isso futuro para gente
conseguir enxergar as coisas do futuro
eu tenho a samba tech ela falou futuro
por exemplo na internet vai ser em vídeo
oitenta por cento do conteúdo que vai
ser produzido na internet até 2020 vai
sem vídeo se você sabe que isso vai ter
no futuro por que que hoje você vai
fazer um conteúdo em texto ou em outro
formato se você percebe que o futuro vai
ser vídeo você começa a fazer alguma
coisa para se preparar para esse futuro
pega essa folha dobra no meio favor
vamos fazer uma coisa diferente com essa
folha então abra essa folha
e eu queria fazer uma experiência
sensorial com vocês hoje durante essa
nossa trajetória aqui nesse teste
primeira coisa eu queria que de um lado
da folha você pegasse uma caneta um
lápis que você tem aí e desenha uma
coisa que represente você vem aqui no
meio e uma coisa que represente o futuro
qualquer coisa que na sua opinião vai
ter no futuro coloca uma coisa de um
lado você e do outro lado do futuro e no
cantinho bem no cantinho aqui embaixo eu
queria que na vertical você escrevesse
uma coisa que você não quer ver no
futuro então coloca aqui no cantinho uma
coisa que você não quer ver no futuro e
no meio uma coisa que você quer ver no
futuro e do outro lado algo que presente
você
me coloca aí bem rapidinho que a gente
vai interagir a gente vai fazer um
negócio de bacana aí com essa folha
e todo mundo colocou guardem essa folha
aí com vocês e eu queria que a gente
tivesse entendendo o quê para você fazer
algo com futuro você tem que fazer algo
hoje você tem que tocar você tem que
sentir e para tocar e para sentir eu
queria que a gente fizesse uma coisa
diferente com essa folha para a gente
mudar o nosso tato e aprender a usar
coisas de hoje eu queria ensinar você
está fazendo um barquinho de origami
vamos fazer um bate rapidinho tropa do
meio pega o seu papel todo mundo dobra
no meio quem nunca aprender fazer um
barquinho vai aprender fazer um
barquinho diferente aqui agora dobro no
meio agora você vai pegar a sua folha e
vai fazer um aviãozinho
e depois você dobrou volta faz um
aviãozinho aqui assim
e pode todo mundo acompanhar aqui vamos
fazer um barquinho ao vivo aqui de
origami e agora você vai pegar a parte
de baixo e vai dobrar de um lado e
dobrar do outro vai fazer como se fosse
um chapeuzinho vou esperar todo mundo
conseguir fazer quem não conseguir pede
ajuda o menino lado que ele ajuda vamos
fez o barquinho é o chapeuzinho agora
você vai pegar a parte de baixo e vai
abrir assim ó como se fosse um losango
se abriram losango e agora eu quero que
você pega a parte de baixo que tá tipo
uma boca e dobra metade para cima vira e
dobra a outra metade para cima você vai
fazer um triângulo agora todo mundo
chegou até aqui ó
e eu vou esperar a quem não conseguiu
pede ajuda amigos lado que ele ajuda
penúltima etapa você vai pegar essa
parte de baixo você vai pegar agora
abrir e virar um losango de novo ó viram
losango
e pegaram e agora a última parte para
quem não sabia puxa com seus dois
indicadores assim ó e você tem um
barquinho bacana esse barquinho eu
queria que representasse a nossa
trajetória de futuro para a gente
entender que você pode ter habilidades e
usar o tato eu queria falar alguns dados
relevantes de hoje o tato fala sobre
você fazer algo hoje você pegar algo e
sentido tem um dado super bacana olha
que dado interessante para quem usa a
internet quem é que usa internet ou como
o negócio como lazer levanta a mão olha
que dado interessante você sabendo que
para carregar uma página que se você tem
um segundo a mais de demora para
carregar uma página você perde até sete
porcento de efetivação na sua venda se a
sua página agora não segunda mais você
sete porcento das pessoas existem de uma
compra se você fatura meu reais por dia
por exemplo no final de um mês você
perdeu 25 mil no final do ano você no
final do ano você perdeu 25 mil isso
quer dizer que você perdeu quase um mês
de faturamento olha que interessante
fazer coisas ao vivo é uma das coisas
mais importantes para você desenvolver o
futuro
e aí você desenvolver o futuro hoje
fazendo uma coisa ao vivo que envolva o
tato eu vou pedir o pessoal jogar um
plástico bolha pode passar um plástico
bolha a gente vai passar um plástico
vôlei para vocês orarem a nossa ideia
que você estivesse experiências
sensoriais hoje então pode jogar o
plástico bolha vai passando aí durante a
palestra esse plástico bolha vai
passando por você e aquele tipo uma rola
de plástico bolha aí vai passando pode
estourando a gente vai jogar os
clássicos você tem para você estourar o
pessoal de cima tá bem profissional
lavanda aí vai jogando o pessoal de
baixo vai jogando vai voltando pode
jogar rápido olha só cima tá realmente
profissional aí no plástico bolha
a entender como pode ser o seu sentido e
como você fazer sentido no mundo de hoje
enquanto você tocar igual que você
sentir e vamos você fazer coisas ao vivo
perceber que as pessoas não são robôs
não são uma máquina que as pessoas estão
sentir seu cheiro tocar quando você
sente isso e quando você faz parte disso
o seu futuro muda e você começa a ter
uma experiência mais interessante para o
seu presente para a gente entender o
futuro entendeu o presente é muito
importante que a gente entenda que não é
só feito de experiências que você fez
hoje você é feito de experiências do
passado também e para isso eu queria que
a gente falasse um pouquinho sobre o
fato que é o sentido que mais faz a
gente lembrar do passado vou falar mais
um dado curioso para vocês a mesma área
do cérebro que faz o olfato é a área que
faz a lembrança tem uma experiência que
os alunos de raiva te fizeram super
bacana que eles deram um lápis para as
pessoas com óleo e deram lápis sem óleo
pelo menos um grupo de pessoas por mesmo
número de pessoas em grupos diferentes
pode ser após
é a hora que você sentir quando eles
deram os dois lápis para dois grupos
diferentes duas semanas depois eles
voltaram e perguntaram para as pessoas
descreverem um lápis o grupo que tinha
um cheiro no lápis lembrou noventa e
dois por cento dos detalhes do lápis o
grupo que não tinha um cheiro lembrou só
de 27 por cento dos detalhes do lado o
olfato é uma das coisas que mais que faz
você lembrar do passado quem é que
lembra do cheiro da casa da sua avó
levanta a mão quem é mexendo na casa da
vó quem lembra do cheiro de pipoca
querendo cheiro de pipoca vou passar ali
ó tempo eu só fazer uma pipoca que
depois da para espalhar o cheiro aí para
vocês foi de propósito que a gente vai
ser aquela pipoca no final desse bloco
vocês vão poder comer pipoca à vontade
oficialmente do tet mas é legal você
perceber que cheiro é uma coisa que traz
memórias lembranças pega o seu barquinho
todo mundo pega o parquinho agora e ele
escreve para mim uma lembrança que você
tenha quer dar o contrário pega seu
barquinho faz assim ao contrário escreve
aqui no meio do casco uma lembrança
feliz que você tem da sua infância
é bacana que você teve aí do seu passado
escreve aí rapidinho todo mundo que tem
uma lembrança feliz pode ser uma
lembrança que você tem do seu pai igual
e contou pode ser uma lembrança que você
tenha de algo que você fez no passado
que te lembrou algo e eu queria que você
lembrasse do cheiro que essa lembrança
traz o cheiro é uma das coisas mais
bacanas criativa sua memória qual é o
cheiro que a sua marca tem você tem um
produto você tem um negócio você tem uma
amizade você tem um jeito de lidar com
as pessoas qual é a marca que você deixa
pensar no passado só que agora para
gente acabar essa parte sensorial de
entender os sentidos é muito importante
entender o futuro entender o presente
entendeu passado mas tudo isso só faz
sentido quando você entende que para
você sentir o cheiro para você respirar
para você sentir e para você olhar o
futuro é importante que a gente tenha
gosto das coisas o paladar eu gosto
muito porque o paladar é o único dos
sentidos que você só consegue fazer de
propósito você pode até olhar uma coisa
sem querer você pode sentir uma coisa
sem
a tocar sem querer mas para pôr na sua
boca você vai ter porque você ninguém
come nada sem querer nem da boca você
que escolhe o que você vai poder na sua
boca e eu queria fazer uma experiência
bacana já que eles falam sobre propósito
e fazer de propósito é tem uma pesquisa
super bacana também consolidados quer um
dado super interessante que olha só que
maluco esse dado quando você tem algo
para fazer hoje em dia por dentro
turismo quando você quer conhecer o
lugar hoje em dia mais de trinta por
cento do crescimento acontece não lembro
sendo turismo mas a indústria do turismo
de experiências as pessoas não querem
mais uma coisa só não eu não quero ir
para nova york estátua da liberdade eu
quero para nova york comer no
restaurante e no restaurante eu ver essa
tua liberdade eu não quero ir mais para
austrália só para ver o canguru eu quero
ir para austrália para pular no banco
jampa igual um canguru eu não quero ir
para recife conhecer só a praia como
chama praia mais famosa de vocês aqui
e eu não quero ir só para essa praia eu
quero fazer o que eu quero ir para
balada eu quero ir para o macaxeira né
pessoal falou que vai cair legal eu
quero ter uma experiência comestível
junto eu quero fazer algo bacana então
eu queria proporcionar para vocês uma
experiência sensorial ao vivo para você
degustar algo agora do lado de você e
tem pessoas que têm caixinhas de
pirulito que explode na boca distribuam
agora pode distribuir trigo e aí todo
mundo vai ter um pirulito que pode
destruir para todo mundo calado
distribuam aí perto de você e tem alguém
que tem uma caixinha pega aí pode
experimentar é um pirulito que tem um
pozinho que explode na boca experiências
sensoriais qual foi a última vez que
você proporcionou de propósito uma
experiência sensorial eu preparei
assistência para vocês e para fazer isso
não foi sem querer eu fiz de propósito
eu comprei esse pirulito antes eu
cheguei mais cedo distribuindo as
pessoas quando você faz algo de
propósito a chance de você degustar algo
muito melhor é muito melhor e quando
você percebe que esse paladar você
conseguiu degustar isso aí você tá
pronto para ter essa explosão de sabores
aí na sua
e a sua boca agora nesse momento para
acabar o nosso encontro de hoje eu
queria falar que toda essa jornada só
faz sentido quando você escuta o que
acontece no caminho aí muito importante
você pensar no futuro você sentir algo
no presente você lembrar das suas boas
memórias do passado você proporcionar
experiências onde as pessoas que
experimentem coisas novas mas tudo isso
a trajetória só faz sentido quando você
conseguir escutar o que as pessoas têm
para descontar o seu redor eu queria
fazer a nossa última nossa penúltima
coisa de hoje que é o seguinte olhem
para as pessoas ao seu redor olha
rapidinho para elas todo mundo olha
a e agora eu queria contar uma história
para vocês para você fazer a próxima
parte como a história que o bill gates é
o cara mais rico do mundo hoje quando
estava estudando na universidade de
harvard ele tinha um professor super
severo falava assim se algum dia algum
aluno tira 10 na minha primeira prova eu
paro o seu professor de raiva de melhor
universidade do mundo e virou sócio de
semana conta a história que o bill gates
tirou 96 na prova desse professor dez
anos depois esse professor estiver um
matéria no jornal escrito assim porque
eu me arrependi de não ter dado 10 para
o bill gates o cara silenciosa que ela
vai ser no mundo olha para consultar o
seu redor e rapidinho agora imagina que
essa pessoa vai ser o próximo viu gates
e agora abraça essa pessoa de acordo com
isso vamos lá olá é
e aí
g1
e mudou a sua percepção sim ou não
quando você percebe que escutar
trajetória muda a sua percepção você
começa a gerar valor tem um cara super
bacana que escreveu e inclusive ele fez
um ted que chama quércia daniele quarta
é um cara que fez uma pesquisa ele fez
um aplicativo super bacana que você
consegue entender dois caminhos é um
aplicativo como se fosse um ex e da vida
só que você pode escolher entre dois
caminhos o caminho mais curto e o mais
eficiente ou caminho mais feliz e ele
foi nesse software nesse aplicativo tudo
que tem de feliz aquele caminho que
geralmente é mais longo mas é mais feliz
naquele caminho tem um parque para você
escutar o barulho dos passarinhos
cantando naquele caminho tem um
restaurante que o dono senta com você
ensina a fazer a receita fazer
experiências com as pessoas é isso é
quando você percebe que é muito mais
legal do que você ir para o restaurante
do que você chamar uma amiga que você
conheceu no tinder para conhecer você
procura para um restaurante indiano que
é mais legal você procura para sua casa
aprender uma restaurante uma receita
indiana com você fica mais legal quando
você tem experiência eu queria provar
é uma experiência agora que a nossa
penúltima experiência de hoje pega por
favor agora o seu telefone a primeira
vez não ted que você vai ligar o seu
telefone liga aí o telefone todo mundo
rapidinho
ah eu queria que você pegar o seu
telefone agora e quando você fizer de
alguém você liga e fala só que agora
queria fazer um caminhão contrário eu
queria que você escolhesse uma pessoa
que fez algo relevante na sua vida como
link falou pode ser pai sua mãe seu
amigo seu professor escolhe uma pessoa
que fez algo relevante na sua vida e eu
queria que você ligasse nesse momento
para pessoa e falasse assim ó eu tô aqui
no meio de um ted e o cara que pediu
para ligar só para falar muito obrigado
eu tô te ligando para agradecer e ouvir
o que a pessoa tem para falar de volta
para você você vai ter um minutos para
fazer isso é verdade tenta ligar agora
valendo não é para mandar mensagem não é
para mandar o whatsapp é para ligar e
ouvir a voz da pessoa tenta realmente
perceber como faz diferença quando você
faz algo que envolve uma ação sua e não
simplesmente uma recepção sua que você
faz algo vou dar 45 segundos para você
acabar sua ligação valendo
olá pessoal olhando daqui o rosto de
vocês antes e o rosto de vocês agora é
outro rosto vocês são muito mais feliz
fazendo essa ligação sim ou não
144 mariana tá com exceção daqueles que
ligaram sei lá para o marido para mulher
ele falou que você fez só você concorda
que você tá mais feliz fazer essa
ligação sim ou não você fez o dia da
pessoa mais feliz sim ou não mas mais
importante do que isso vamos supor que
você precisa dessa pessoa daqui a três
meses você ter feito essa ligação agora
ela vai te atender um pouco mais
receptivo um pouco mais alegre a próxima
vez que você ligar sim ou não você
influenciou o futuro fazendo algo no
presente eu queria encerrar nosso
encontro de hoje pessoal fazendo algo
que você possa lembrar de entender o que
te faz o sentido quando você fala dos
sentidos da vida e eu queria pegar o seu
barquinho que você desenhou vamos pegar
todo mundo barquinho
e eu queria tirar uma foto nesse nosso
barquinho levanta o barquinho todo mundo
conseguiu fazer um barquinho levanta o
barquinho pessoal do de dex aí vai tirar
uma foto oficial da jornada do nosso
futuro que representado por esse
barquinho olharam esse barquinho você
começa a navegar hoje por mares nunca
dantes navegados eu quero falar para
vocês que vocês vão enfrentar
tempestades sabe qual a tempestade que
inventar falta de tempo é uma tempestade
sim ou não agora corta aí um quarto do
seu arquinho pode usar um pedaço
razoável do seu marquinha um quinto do
seu barquinho pode rasgar é a tempestade
da falta de tempo você vai querer fazer
um futuro melhor mas vai faltar sabe o
que vai faltar dinheiro muitas vezes é
falta budget porta aí uma parte do seu
barquinho
e você ainda vai querer continuar um
futuro melhor mais tarde uma parte muito
difícil vai ser falta de apoio você vai
querer fazer as coisas mas nem todo
mundo vai te apoiar rasga agora um terço
da sua vela pode rasgar um terço da vela
oi e aí agora você vai olhar para o seu
barquinho falar o que lascou mas eu
queria falar para você se não as cores
pessoa o futuro é feito quando você
entende que existem caminho os melhores
para você fazer que dá para criar um
caminho diferente para esse futuro o
lembra essa essa coisa aqui faça um
caminho diferente fizeram existem outros
caminhos para serem feitos e o que eu
queria hoje é que você construir seu
futuro aonde você perceber se abra o seu
marquinhos agora vão cuidado quem ficou
com alguma pontinha tira o meu ficou sem
pontinha todo mundo segura assim
marquinha todo mundo segura assim abra
você vai tem assim pessoal eu queria
falar que o nosso futuro é feito de
pessoas que conseguem fazer hoje a coisa
mais importante para nós possuímos um
futuro muito melhor para todo mundo que
é você entender aqui no final das contas
o que você tem que fazer para dar
sentido na sua vida é vestir a camisa de
quem você é da das suas conquistas das
suas lembranças é isso que eu tinha que
falar muito obrigado valeu pessoal é
e essa foto do barquinho daqui a pouco a
gente vai publicar aqui fábrica de
criatividade deles ficar que foi um
prazer tá com você gente muito obrigado
e até o próximo valeu o